could you do me a quick favor if you're
listening to this please hit the follow
or subscribe button it helps more than
you know and we invite subscribers in
every month to watch the show in person
think of james bond in real life barely
says anything not a hint of humanity
this would be a terrible person to have
a relationship with and we've been
taught that that's what women want
number one youtube channel in the world
for dating and new york's times
best-selling author matthew hussey let's
begin we have to dispense with this idea
that the one exists someone becomes the
one by what we build with them any
commitment long term requires true
effort i had an issue with my head and
my ear it created the darkest moments of
my entire life
i'd always found whatever was going on
in my life i could fix it
i couldn't fix it
if i removed it what would i remove from
matthew hassou
imagine that you're not being judged on
anything but how great a chef you are we
spend so much of our lives mourning our
ingredients don't aspire to have the
best ingredients aspire to be the best
chef
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo
usa edition i hope nobody's listening
but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
matthew
before we started recording we were
having a conversation about how the
thing that gets you your glory in your
own words can often be your downfall
and it always tends to be the case that
the start of everyone's journey
especially when i sit here with people
that i consider to be anomalies like you
there tends to be some kind of anomalous
um
situation or trauma or exacerbating
factor that they can point to and say
that was probably
the the poke from life or the thing that
happened in my early years that resulted
in me becoming the man i am today have
you been able to identify exactly what
that is in your own life
i think so
to a large extent i mean we had a lot of
financial insecurity growing up and
i never knew if everything was going to
be okay or not
for me it was usually it started out as
a major
bid for control
i wanted control over my situation
and
i
i remember we were living in a in a
trailer at one point in my teenage years
and you know things were you know a
certain way at home and you know i
everyone loved each other but it was
there was a lot of tension as you can
imagine
and
i i remember going into school and
saying i'm
you know
i'm gonna do this and i'm gonna do that
and i would speak so
forcefully and aggressively
about where i was going
but it and what was funny is there was a
i remember a girl at school who had
never noticed me before
um
one of the popular girls she said my mom
wants me to marry you
and i said
i said why she said because she thinks
you're going to be rich
which
so for me
even though it's a fairly shallow thing
to say
there was something about that that was
interesting to me at the time because i
thought oh my god i
i've never been
further from that reality
but from the way i'm talking someone
really believes me
someone really believes that i'm going
to be something or i'm going to go
somewhere
but at the time i it what it really was
was i was just
afraid and didn't want to be at the
mercy of
of life didn't want to be at the mercy
of
whatever i had in my head as the the bad
out there that could come and get you if
you didn't
get control
and
and i think most of my early adult life
was defined by
an obsessive need for
control
when people say that to me i often
presume that that meant something was
out of control
well i think for me as a kid it was
because i felt like there were problems
when we had financial difficulties i
felt like there were problems i couldn't
solve
i wasn't
they were too big i wasn't able to do
anything about them
so
as i
as soon as i got the chance to go out
there and do something
that that became a kind of
obsession
and i think by the way combining that
with an insecurity
that i was just
desperate to feel
special in some way
desperate to feel important in some way
so
you know i defined normal as bad
whatever normal is and i always felt
like i had to do something different
i had to do something that was you know
when i was a when i was a i
my dad when i was a kid he owned a
nightclub
and i was a dj in that nightclub from 14
years old um he was a dj when he first
bought that nightclub uh he went in
there well actually the nightclub needed
a dj and they didn't have one so he
started djing that was how he became a
dj
and
and then through my teenage years i did
that but but i didn't just dj for fun i
mean i was like
you know while all my friends were going
to parties and doing that kind of thing
i was always the one djing the party i
was always the one working i was always
the one when everyone was going home at
2am i was going home at 2am to unload
the car and all of the equipment and you
know it but in my head i think it was
still coming from that place of
it was it was ambition but it was
ambition i think driven by a kind of
insecurity
control and i just wanted to feel
special
what was your relationship like with
with women in your early years so like
when you're 16
odd years old and we start to get those
first sort of
we think they're real but uh real
heartbreaks crushes romances
i was shy
i was i was quite it's not that i wasn't
i was
a likeable teenager i was
i was good with people to the extent
that i was
i was kind i wanted to be liked i wanted
to be close to people
i kind of got on with everyone at school
like there was no one there was no group
that i belonged to necessarily i could
hang with the guys who played football i
could hang with the guys who you know
played dungeons and dragons there was no
one there was no one that i didn't like
or get on with
but i
when if it came to someone i thought was
attractive
then it was i couldn't
i i could not be my
fun self my best self my confident self
then i would kind of freeze up
and that was
sort of you know in a way
i was
how old was i i was about 11 or 12 when
i first picked up how to win friends and
influence people off my dad's bookshelf
my dad was always into self-development
so i picked up that book and i was
i was
really immediately taken by this idea
that you could
be better with people
and that there were skills you could
learn that weren't necessarily the
things we were being taught in school
that that really could magnify your
impact or the opportunities that you
were able to have access to
and
as a teenager one of the ways that that
sort of manifests itself is oh i might
be able to talk to a girl i like
so
that was one of my early kind of
self-development journeys for myself
was just trying to get the courage to be
able to talk to someone that i liked
because i realized early on oh the
the girl that i'm dating right now chose
me
i'm dating her because she happened to
be the one who
asked me out or at school whose friend
came and asked me out on her behalf
and that's why i'm
dating this person right now it's not
because i
went to choose who i liked is because
someone decided they like me and i said
well i'm not going to have the
confidence to go and talk to someone i
really like
so i guess i'll say yes
and that was sort of i would say that
defined my early
sort of teenage years with girls when
you in your late teenagers what was your
i want to be this when i grow up what
were you thinking that your career was
going to be when you were 18 years old
at one point i thought i'm going to do
this djing thing this is going to be my
life and
my dream was kind of i loved
self-development i really loved i i was
14 when i got
taken to a tony robbins seminar really
in england
at the excel center
when i think of the people in society
generally that
are seen as special and important and
have the admiration of crowds it's
definitely the first two things that
come to mind is like tony robbins and dj
well i loved i loved music
that was something that
really is a
that's always been true in my life i've
always loved music even at my events
today music play a big part plays a big
part because i've just never lost that
love
but i also just love ideas there's
nothing more fun to me than just
discussing an idea but did you love the
the attention
and the admiration
yeah probably i know i did i i think i
still there's a part of me that
that can be hijacked by that
what are the symptoms of letting the ego
drive for too long
i think
firstly living in a constant state of
never enough
living in a state of fear that you'll
never
be enough
and feeling
ultimately disconnected
from
from from the results of things
from how good things are already
and
and when you when you achieve that thing
there is a
ultimately
uh
a scary moment awaits because it's not
it's not just a numbness there is a
there is a feeling of total
disconnection and when that happens
panic sets in
and it's a terrible feeling it's a
terrible feeling because
it then you really freak out because as
long as you're telling yourself
yeah life is really hard now but when
that happens it won't be so hard as long
as you're telling yourself that what you
have to hold on to is hope
and the hope will drive you even if
you're unhappy today
but when you arrive and it doesn't work
then hope goes away
matt damon won the the oscar at 27 for
good will hunting
and graham norton i always remember
watching this interview where graham
norton said to matt damon on his show
you know
how does it feel
when you were 27 and you won an oscar
something people worked their whole
lives to do how did you feel
he said i went home
my girlfriend
went to bed or went to sleep and graham
norton joked like so you didn't even get
laid on oscar night
he goes my girlfriend went to sleep
and i laid in bed and i i had this oscar
in my hand and i just felt so sad
because i imagined this
this version of me
kind of in a parallel universe that had
worked his whole life to get this
and then realized
70 years later that this wasn't it this
wasn't the thing that worked
um
and so i think that when when that ego
is driving and that ego is never fed
it's always hungry it's always wanting
more
um there is there is the danger of just
constant
comparison nothing ever being enough
and ultimately anytime you do get
something you think might be enough you
feel completely and utterly disconnected
from the result after
the initial high
of it which is no different from a drug
fix here's the hard part because we've
heard this a thousand times we all think
that
you know i get it i get it when you get
money it's not gonna make you happy when
you get status that's not gonna make you
happy when you become known that's not
gonna make you happy we all
we all can regurgitate that
and then five minutes later we're back
to chasing it in our own lives
and and what's curious to me is how do
you take something that is a
bumper sticker
phrase
and turn it into a kind of meaningful
practical way of
living and reconnecting so that you
don't fall prey
to not taking that advice that we all
can
say it because it sounds good
how do we do that
i
if you have a hazard i guess
i'll tell you well i'll
i'll talk about what
i do
i'm i firstly
am very
aware of the simple things that make me
happy
and i
i have them written down i was saying to
you before we started i'm a big note
taker i'm someone who
i believe winston churchill said people
occasionally stumble over the truth
but most pick themselves up and carry on
as if nothing happened
well
i would say the reason i write so much
when i feel something if i feel
something good if i feel an emotion that
i like
whether it's peace
or happiness or i feel connected
or i feel love
for something or someone
i don't anymore just pick myself up and
keep going when i stumble over an
emotion like that i i pause life
i go okay hold
on what's happening right now
why am i feeling this
i can just kind of treat emotions as an
accident
or i can try to bottle them
and figure out what's my formula
for getting to this feeling of peace i
feel peaceful right now
i don't feel peaceful a lot
this isn't like my tendency is towards
anxiety
i don't feel peace a lot so when i feel
peace i want to know how i got here
how did i stumble into this wonderful
room
and i look at it i go what's going on
around me
what was i just thinking about
that led to this thought that led to the
thought that
what what was the chain of thoughts that
got me here who am i with right now
what did i just do
because what i want is a formula for
getting back there again
an hour from now when life does its
thing because it will five minutes later
life will do its thing i'll read an
email i'll get a phone call
someone will say something that annoys
me and there is it's gone
i need a place where i can get back to
that and i need that formula
so i i call these emotional buttons
i have a list of emotional buttons in my
phone on my computer
and i teach this on my retreat
but it started from this was selfishly
just something i did for me and to this
day
is i'm always suspicious when someone
teaches something
but you never see them using that thing
you never see them doing that thing
i because not because that makes them a
hypocrite it just i feel like how
important can it be if you don't do it
this emotional buttons concept i live
this concept because
when i wake up in the morning what i do
is i immediately wake up and i look at
these little formulas
and usually there's one thing that
kind of triggers that formula
if i can the reason i call them
emotional buttons is because
if there's if there's one
idea or thought
or youtube video
or person even an idea of a person if
there's one thing that can connect me to
that formula
then
i can get there instantly
so like i don't know um
anthony bourdain who who i really
loved he did jujitsu and he was really
really into it
i do jujitsu most mornings when i wake
up and do jiu jitsu i don't want to do
it
i really don't
i'm so hot every time i come home from
doing it i'm like i'm so glad i went
that was so good i'm so why don't i do
this all the time
i almost
never feel like going
and
therefore i have emotional buttons that
get me to
to want to go to jiu jitsu i have these
little triggers one of them is a
two-minute youtube video where anthony
bourdain is being asked about jiu-jitsu
and he speaks about it and the way he
speaks about it
and because i feel connected to him as
an individual it makes me go
oh i want to go
i want to go.
or there was a rich role had a phrase
mood follows action
and that one phrase became an emotional
button for me because i went oh mood
follows action this is so great i don't
need i don't even need to feel
like going before i go do you write your
emotional buttons down somewhere yes yes
in your notes or something yes you say
jiu jitsu this is my exactly exactly
it gets that specific for me that they
become a kind of manual
for living for me now the reason i say
all of this even though this might seem
disconnected from the idea
of uh
of not allowing ego to rule and being
connected to what's important
is
is that this whole concept what it's
really about is being connected
in life
what i experienced a lot in my 20s which
was really scary at a certain point
was
on paper i'm doing everything that i
thought i wanted to do
i
when i was a teenager i was
i was reading self-development books and
talking about them for fun
i'd grab uni mates and be like let me
tell you about this thing that i just
read and i'd have some very patient
friends at uni who would be like tell me
more that's really interesting
i would do that just for fun
at 27 i'm doing it for an audience of
millions of people
with a best-selling book and tv shows
and all these things i'm doing this
on the most incredible level this thing
that i would do for free for fun
and i can't feel it why can't i feel it
what's happening
and
i had someone once say to me at the time
you're disconnected
and at the time i just couldn't i
couldn't even i didn't even know what
that meant
i just said i don't i i'm not i feel
somehow like i'm on the outside of my
own life
and
and what i've come to truly believe in
at my core
is that
so much of life is just about getting
connected when when we
you know whether it's simon sinek
talking about the power of why
or anybody who's saying you need to find
your motivation or
it all ends up being about the same
thing really which is
are you connected
do you feel connected to why this thing
you're about to do whether it's a
conversation with a friend or a podcast
or going to the gym
do you feel connected to why
that's even important to you
not important in the world and blah blah
blah everyone wants to change the world
why it's important to you
what makes it meaningful
to you
that level of connection a friend of
mine aubrey marcus put it
i don't know whether it was his or
someone else's but he put it as being on
the inside of the moment
when there's a moment happening do you
feel like you're on the inside
of the moment
or do you feel like you're on the
outside looking in
and and
every day i wake up and the first thing
on my on my best days there are days
where life gets in the way and i rush
straight into work and i always pay the
price for that when i rush straight into
work and emails and and all of that i
pay the price for that
but more often than not
the way i start my morning is to wake up
i
get out my emotional buttons
the things that remind me what's
important to me and what makes me feel
good and connect me to those things
and i read those and i write sometimes i
just write them out again
i don't get creative i just i just write
them out again and as i write them i
connect to them again
and i play beautiful music i play music
that makes me feel really connected and
usually not with words just just
a track as an instrumental
and that process
immediately begins my day with a feeling
of
of being on the inside of my life
instead of waking up and getting dragged
through my day
when we think about the things that make
people disconnected from their lives or
causes them to live on the outside of
the moment because i was as you were
saying that i was thinking about the
listener and i was thinking there's
going to be so many people listening to
this now that have
you know veered off course of alignment
they've been dragged they're good you
know there's something called the i
think it's called the excellence
syndrome or something or the curse of
excellence where you're so good at
something
that people start paying you more and
more to do it and you keep accepting the
money and what you're what you're not
ever asking yourself is you're being
paid more and more to do this thing that
you were good at or you were qualified
in is is it in alignment with myself you
get 10 years down the line and people
have these like mid-life crises or
burnout because they're so far from
themselves but the temptation or the
money or the the applause was able to
drag them away
um
from your from your personal experience
what was it that was dragging you out of
alignment we talked a little bit about
our ego there but was there anything
else that we haven't covered where you
go that is the thing that keeps drifting
me off course
it's interesting because i remember i
was thinking as you're talking as well
about the study about the impact money
has on our motivation and you can take a
task as you you know you're a kid and
you like doing personal development you
can take a task that someone once loved
doing and when they introduce
financial remuneration in the studies
people's motivation to do that exact
same thing drops
it's mad isn't it mad
yeah makes no sense well there's a um
there's a study that involves two rats
one of them is on a wheel
that
it controls
the the rat can run whenever it wants to
run
there's that's right a rat b
is on another wheel but rap b's wheel is
hooked up to rat a's wheel
so
rat b doesn't get to decide
rat a
whenever that rat runs
rat b's wheel moves and rat b has to run
they're both doing the exact same amount
of exercise
but
the results of the experiment are the ra
a has all of the markers
associated with
all the positive markers associated with
exercise
rat b has all of the negative markers
associated with stress um
they're both running the exact same
amount they're not do one's not doing
more exercise than the other but one is
choosing
and the other one is having to
when we start to think that we're no
longer choosing
when we're now having to do something
it could be the exact same thing
that we were doing before we used to be
rat a
but now because it made money and with
that money we went and
bought a house and we got an expensive
mortgage and we got the car and we did
this we did that or we just had the
expectation now because our identity is
built on earning that much money so it
might not even be the stuff that's
weighing you down it's your identity
that's weighing you down and the
perception you want other people to have
of you or retain of you
that now has turned you into rat b
you're no longer choosing
this thing
so i'm fascinated by that
idea and and i think that
as much as there will be people in life
listening to this who
have maybe grown tired of what they're
doing
and therefore have concluded that they
need to do something else
sometimes that's true
sometimes it's reconnecting
with what you do
from a different place
and there are a lot of people that have
convinced themselves that
happiness lies in a career change
happiness lies in them going in a
different direction
and we when we do that we glorify
everyone else's job
we think everyone else does a better job
than me everyone else has something more
exciting going everyone else has
something that oh i wish i was where
that person is
but
that's not true either
there was an imagineer at disney who who
was one of the main imagineers
responsible for a lot of animal kingdom
in disney world
and he got asked do you ever not feel
excited about a project you're given
and he said sure he said but my job is
to find
what's exciting
about the project i just got given
and i think there's something important
in that because we're often seeking
passion elsewhere instead of
creating the passion
where we are i'm not saying every job is
made equal
in terms of its ability to
allow you to do that
but i do think that um
there's a lot more room to
there's a lot more room to experience
passion within the confines of where we
already are than we think when we're
constantly trying to change our
environment to make things better
one of the three lines of like i guess
business but life in general and also
with relationships is and i really
wanted to ask you this because it's
something that i've seen in my dms from
people people sometimes message me about
relationships and one of the things that
i find concerning when i meet someone in
their personal development journey or in
my dm's talking about their boyfriend or
in other facets of business is when i
identify a lack of
personal and self-responsibility where
you meet certain people in life where
they just can never seem to take
responsibility they never want to like
look in the mirror and ask themselves
the question what role have i played in
this and i sat with lewis in london on
this podcast about a week ago or two
weeks ago something and one of the
things that really astounded me about
lewis was when he said something about
his ex-partner
even if it was it seemed like a fault on
the surface he would say and that's on
me and then end the little the paragraph
with why he was responsible even if it
was like you know she wouldn't let me
have females on my podcast or something
like that then he'd say and that's on me
and i remember thinking damn this guy's
gonna go far
so what role have you seen that part
taking personal responsibility has on
the the positivity of your outcomes
in dating life business and everything
in between
well i think that
to start with it it makes you a much
more likeable person amen
the idea of extreme ownership
is a in some ways powerful
but
we all know there are things that have
happened in life that
are not our fault at all there are
things that we trauma we have
experienced that it would be
insulting
to say that
we have to take responsibility for these
things
uh it would be sinister in some cases to
suggest that
but
if we can get into the habit of
genuinely saying
you know how this how this is affecting
me is something i can take
responsibility for and if i do it
actually gives me a shot at feeling
better about this thing it actually
gives me a chance
of
improving it because if i if i say i'm
powerless
then i can't have it both ways
i can't say i'm powerless and none i i i
have no responsibility over how i feel
and then make it better
i have to say
okay this thing is happening it's not
that it's happening is not my fault that
someone is making my life really really
difficult right now with what they're
doing their behavior
their abuse their whatever
that is not my fault
but
i want to get really curious
about how i can
handle this
in a better way in a more productive way
and the one of the things our mutual
friend louis howes who you're talking
about one of the beautiful things about
him
both
in front of the camera and behind the
camera
is that he is lewis is not a complainer
lewis is someone who
he'll talk about the things that that
he's struggling with right now or he'll
talk about the things that he's trying
to work on
but it's never from a place of being
the victim
it's always from a place of what what
can i do
which i think is different people i
think what part of the problem for a lot
of people is they conflate the idea of
ownership with fault
and
and that takes us into some really
dangerous territory it it's not your
fault that something's happening
but
you can take responsibility for
how you
how you turn that into art
i i thought about um
i thought about confidence a lot
in my career
and the injustices of confidence right
because the
we are not distributed things equally in
life you're not distributing things
equally at birth we're not distributed
opportunities equally
you know it's super easy for anyone
who's
objectively decent looking to talk about
you know
how easy it is to go and approach
someone or do this or do that and you're
like
you cannot even imagine
what it is for someone who has been
rejected their entire
lives
they are starting from a completely
different position than you in their
confidence it's so easy for someone to
say you just need to be confident okay
start from where i'm starting from and
then tell me that
you know
the
confidence is a really
again it can be a very insulting concept
but i do believe
that that there's a i there's a tv show
called chopped and i i'm probably i'm
not familiar with the show but so i'm
probably going to get wrong the concept
but in my head the concept of this show
is very very
interesting from the point of view of
confidence
i think
the chefs get given different
ingredients
so
you you it's like just
lucky dip what do you get
what's interesting is
if you get a basket of ingredients and i
get a basket of ingredients
we're both getting judged on what we
make of those ingredients
in that format it's what are you able to
do with what you have and what am i able
to do with what i have
and i think there's something really
fascinating about that because we spend
so much of our lives mourning our
ingredients
really being upset or frustrated about
what the ingredients are that we were
given
imagine that you're not being judged on
anything but how great a chef you are
because that show isn't about
ingredients it's about chefs
well imagine life isn't about
ingredients it's about chefs
don't aspire to have the best
ingredients
aspire to be the best chef
and the best chef
is going to be the one who can be the
most creative
with the ingredients that they have
i i'm fascinated by that because if i
apply that to my own life i just go
whatever thing that just happened i wish
didn't happen
whatever thing that's happened to me
this year that is so painful
so devastating so whatever whatever that
thing is
it just became a new ingredient
in my life
i can either judge myself or my
ingredients
which if i do that i'm always at the
mercy of the next thing that happens in
my life
something cataclysmic could happen in my
life and and i lose everything and then
what i'm going to judge myself and my
life on my ingredients
it to me it's always
how great of a chef
are you
ingredients are luck of the draw
being a chef
is something we can continue to get
better at our entire lives and it's
actually the
antidote
to whatever happens if you're a great
chef
you can cook something out of whatever
you have
it's such a such a powerful analogy and
it really really did like yeah i
sort of do what you probably do when you
hear an analogy you kind of test it from
multiple scenarios and it really stands
up and i was thinking then again about
when we look into that basket of the
ingredients we're handed if we if we
believe that the ingredients we were
handed are inadequate or inferior to the
chef stood next to us we're probably
also going to prepare the meal with a
certain level of pessimism that's going
to result in a worse dish anyway and the
the agony also of looking over at
someone else's basket of ingredients and
going [ __ ] oh they've got the ribeye
and look at me and that you know because
we both know the negative power of
comparison and how it can drive down
performance belief confidence and all
those things but it's a beautiful
beautiful analogy and sometimes
imagine if you took pride in being able
to still make even if you knew like this
ingredient is
this one sucks
like there's no getting around it
these ingredients i have right now suck
but you took pride in
look what i can make out of out of this
i get you made something amazing with
your truffle salt and your you know your
caviar and your uni like i get you did
something amazing with that no [ __ ]
look what i just did with kelp jerky
yeah it's a it's a real powerful um
analogy for privilege as well isn't it
because you know 100 because you then
you realize i'm in a different game
altogether
this is why comparison is so insidious
because
what am i gonna do compare myself
to someone who got a completely
different basket of ingredients and say
and by the way the basket of ingredients
isn't just what you got in life in terms
of circumstances or parents or whatever
education
your basket of ingredients is also
what you got here
you have a sharp mind
thank you
now
you've no doubt honed that mind you've
respected it you've honored it by
reading and by educating yourself into
all of these things
but you also started with a sharp mind
yeah probably i'm really it's funny
because i'm really bad at math english
and everything i'm good at the thing i
honed but you're right i definitely had
a predisposition like your speed
of like you hear something and you i've
watched you in in interviews and when
you talk your speed of how you
assimilate
information
and draw patterns you're good at pattern
recognition which is why from a
philosophical standpoint
there's a strength there right because
you're good at pattern recognition
these things
you just won the lottery on that one
like with your brain
you just happen to win the lottery on
that one
right that's this is going to be my
confidence button
gonna get this
those ingredients extend to everything
they extend to everything you you can
have grown up in the most dire
circumstances
but have a sharpness of mind that other
people can't even relate to
and
for that reason you've if you know how
to double down on that thing
anything can happen
i love the idea
and i think that everyone could
benefit from a kind of acceptance of
just
i'm starting from where i am forget
starting from when you were a baby and
you know all of the circumstances you
were born into and so on i'm talking now
forget what's happened forget everything
you've done i had a great brain but then
for 10 years i did a bunch of drugs and
then i hurt myself and then blah blah
blah whatever doesn't matter i think
about it like this imagine that you woke
up into your life right now and your
only job
was to make the most of that life
so forget the years that stephen has
already had your 29 right now so forget
the 29 years that have already happened
you this brand new soul is waking up
this morning into stephen's body at 29
with whatever his opportunities are and
whatever his problems are
it would be
awesome you'd be so happy for the
opportunity i'd be honestly
[Music]
terrified do you know why
because
i'd lose the lessons as well
and then i think i literally was
thinking of this soul coming down
getting my credit card and going and
buying a lamborghini
he was like he will go back to the club
you start with a 60 year old level of
wisdom but i guess you keep the wisdom
it's so funny i started i was having
this conversation with with uh my fiance
the other day and we were like
we would not go back to our 20s for any
amount of money in the world there is
nothing
i would not take i would not want those
extra years back
if it meant that i didn't have the
lessons that i have today that have
brought me more peace
than i had done
mo gowda sat here and he said when he
was the head of google x
he said that when they did the eraser
test which was asking people if you
could erase the most traumatic
experience of your life these are really
horrific things
but in erasing it you'd erase the
lessons that came with it 99 of people
said no
and it's the same thing it's like i
wouldn't even go back to being younger
if it meant that i'd lose the last 10
years of lessons as you said yeah
because
you you erase that trauma and and you
want to because my god who would want to
go through that but you're playing
roulette with your wisdom yeah who wants
to take that gamble and some trauma
not all of it got to be clear there some
trauma
is a consequence of a lesson we had to
learn and so if you're so
life will probably have to teach you
that lesson again in my my case whether
it's heartbreak or whatever it is or
failure there was a lesson i had to
learn about the nature of the world and
people and if you remove it then i'm
gonna have to learn it again that means
more pain
and that
that trauma that you went through even
if it wasn't a result of something that
you needed to learn
may have been the catalyst for you to
learn something that
is going to prove essential for
something you've yet to experience amen
there are things for me that
have prepared me for the rest of my life
in some way
that
i
i i had an issue with my um
i have an issue with my head and my ear
that bothered me
to say it bothered me is as
is ridiculous it
it created
the darkest moments of my entire life
tinnitus isn't it well i have tinnitus
right it's but it's not tinnitus alone
it's um
it's a it's a kind of a pain and a
throbbing that
that rides up through my ear and my head
it's been very traumatic because there
were times when i was there were times
when
i couldn't
i couldn't
imagine i didn't know what i was gonna
do
it robbed me of all of the joy in life
i i couldn't
i couldn't experience any joy i was so
it was so centralizing this pain this
chronic pain
and i would go through cycles of every
time there was some new treatment that i
thought could help
i would get some hope and that hope
would give me a momentary kind of
for a couple of weeks or a month before
the treatment i would feel uplifted even
though i would still be in pain i would
feel like
there's this thing that's going to work
and i'd talk about it to friends and
family i know i'm they'd be like how's
your head and i'd be like oh it's bad
but but i'm going to go and do this
thing and i did
so many different things and every time
when it didn't work
i would i would plummet even deeper
and
and it got so dark that i didn't know
i thought oh i'm not signing up for this
i can't do this i can't i i cannot do
this for another 50 years
in my head it was the closest i'd ever
been to suicidal
without
truly going there in a practical sense
it was a kind of conceptual thought
where i thought
i'm i can't i can't sign up for this for
the rest of my life
and
because i had
friends that i love family i love more
than anything in this world
staff accompany all of these
things i had a big life
there was never a real option it was
never like a real thing that i'd
considered
but i remember the thought that that
triggered
was
i am just gonna
live for the people that i care about
now i'm just gonna live for other people
whether it's my audience when i make a
video or whether it's by family or
whether it's my team who rely on this
company for their living
i'm going to live for other people
because
i i don't experience joy anymore
this just
this robs me of everything in my life
i'm always thinking about it 24 hours a
day there would be 15 seconds when i'd
first wake up in the morning where i'd
forget
that i wasn't that i was in pain for
just a brief moment
and then it would rush back in and i'd
remember
for me it was the first brush in my life
with anything it was my first brush with
something that
my
ingenuity my determination my ambition
my
intelligence my problem solving could
not
i'd always found whatever was going on
in my life i could fix it
i couldn't fix it and in that sense it
sort of became my first brush with
mortality because i went
i i just have to
i have to somehow learn
how to make peace
here and
in doing that
and and there's a whole conversation to
be had on how i did that but in doing
that
i've now
learned
to deal with something that i know in
one form or another is going to come up
again and again in my life
it may not be in the same context
it might be through
the death of somebody i care about
it might be through some other
traumatic circumstances i can't even
picture right now that are going to
happen to me
but i know that in the process of
handling that trauma
i have become more robust
in my ability to deal with
all manner of chronic conditions in life
that there isn't an easy answer to
if i removed it what would i remove from
matthew hussey
i mean
so
so much i it would remove
an extraordinary amount of empathy
look chronic conditions can come in the
form of physical pain but they can also
come in the form of emotional
pain and and there are people that
when they talk about being depressed or
when they talk about
struggling with anxiety
there's a chronicity to that
that they are dealing with that
is incredibly hard to understand if
you've always been able to make things
go away
there
there is something about a thing you
can't make go away
that
brings you to your knees
and truly truly humbles you
and
and so it wouldn't just take away an
enormous amount of empathy it would take
away an extraordinary amount of humility
to lose that would be to lose i think
the most powerful parts of who i am
today
do you still have the
[Music]
pain now
yeah
but i i what i learned
and this is true for many people with
chronic pain
is that
there is an emotional component
to it
and so
the way that i relate to it is
has the ability to either make worse
that emotional component or reduce it
the the pain is always there waiting to
flare up
and some days it's a four some days it's
a nine
when it's at four
i can get on with my life when it's at a
nine i have to almost do the opposite i
have to practice immense self-compassion
because i'm like you i'm like
i want to wake up every morning and get
after it and there's so many things i
want to do and that's like into a fault
i pack my days and i'm always trying to
and what it taught me was how to slow
down and not beat myself up for slowing
down
because there were days where i was so
miserable with it
that i had to learn how to just be okay
with being miserable today
i'm so unhappy with this today this is
so affecting
that
i can't
do that piece of work that i really want
to do i can't get that thing done i
don't want to hang out with people i
don't want to it
and once i let go of all the
expectations of myself on that day
and said you know what then [ __ ] it
let's just be in pain today
once i did that
that would impact the emotional
component of it
because now i wasn't i wasn't
upset about being in pain
and i wasn't
stressing about being in pain and i
wasn't beating myself up for being in
pain because i felt like
i'm i'm it would even sometimes go to
the core of me being a man
i'd be like i'm weak
i'm deficient somehow i'm not
this you know i don't feel able
and
that that made me feel like an elderly
person in a 30-somethings body
i was like what's wrong this is so they
don't beat myself all of this by the way
is just making the pain flare up
so when i flare up emote when emotions
flare up for me it goes straight there
for me
and
what i learned is oh that's interesting
because
the game now is
can i control stress
or anxiety or self-judgment
or any of the shame any of these things
can i control these
and get a handle on them and reduce them
because for me
there's a very literal consequence
to them going up
and there's a real benefit there's real
treasure to be had in
being able to get a handle on those
things so that again was a gift
very few people will be able to relate
to the chronic pain um experience that
you've had but people will be able to
relate to how their
out of control emotions have an impact
on their broader immune system so when
we get stressed we get ill like for me
in my life when i was running my my
company i would get ill
so rarely that when i did i would know
the email or the situation or the cash
flow issue that had caused it in the
preceding 48 hours i'd go ah [ __ ] yeah
you know and then i'd get a cold right
so it happened like twice a year and it
would always be typically always be when
we had a cash flow problem
um
is there anything you've implemented in
your life to get to get control of your
emotional sort of stress response that
life
you know will um cause because of
whatever's because life happens
whether it's meditation or something
else just to bring yourself back down to
a place of peace
one of the things that's important to me
is to recognize that
the actually what i need to be happy is
not
it's not actually that
impressive
if i get to
i have um
a certain i call them my criteria
my criteria are the things that
need to happen every day for me to
feel like
i'm living
a good life
and therefore my head hits the pillow
and i feel like
today mattered
today was a good day
and i've distilled that down to
a few key words create
move
learn
connect
appreciate
and contribute
interesting and i really thought about
those as like my my personal formula for
happiness
the reason that those words sound quite
vague is because i actually have
many many different ways of achieving
any of them
right now i'm writing a book
it just so happens that
every day i write is contributing to the
goal of producing a book but
even if it wasn't
it still ticks my create box every day
when i sit and write for
45 minutes or an hour
i tick that create box in my criteria
now it doesn't matter whether i'm
writing a book or making a video or
doing something else that's creative i
just have to take that box
i don't by the way have to tick it for
six hours a day
there's diminishing returns
if i do it for one or two hours a day i
take that box
movement or move
i typically i do jiu-jitsu or i do uh
boxing or i'm in the gym
but i could even if if you and i went
for a hike tomorrow i'd meet that
movement box with that
multiple ways of achieving our criteria
but it matters to me immensely
it's everything that i do meet them each
day
and an unhappy life for me is one where
i don't where too many days in a row
i didn't
hit those criteria
it has nothing to do with
how big my book deal is
or how many people watched a video today
or
you know it all those external things
that are stressing me out
because in that moment when i'm stressed
i've convinced myself that that's what
really matters
what helps me is stepping out of that
game altogether and stripping my life
back down
to the absolute basics
if today
i
call my mom or my brother and have a
a nice conversation to connect
if i
go spend an hour doing brazilian jiu
jitsu
if i
uh
write 500 words
if i learn something new from a book
if i help someone that's my contribute
if i help someone
i've done what i need to do
to live a good life
all the rest and none of those things
are dependent on how well everything is
is going in my life
and that that to me is really liberating
because it means all the stress that i'm
creating is is self-imposed
one of those boxes was connect
and you have
connected
with someone
who's actually sat in the room i am
you know you historically not posted a
lot on social media about your
relationship situations you've been as
you said in your own words on that
wonderful proposal announcement post you
did you'd been quite a private person
one of the lines in that that um post
you did when you announced that you and
audrey had become engaged was
and finally thank you for teaching me
how to love in a way that i was too
scared to before
i found that quite intriguing
i
i think like a lot of men
i struggled with
genuine vulnerability
we all have our fake version of
vulnerability
the you know
it's the version of going into for a job
interview and saying my what's your
biggest weakness i i work too hard
everyone's got their pr version of
vulnerability
it's vulnerability if on some level it
just makes me feel like i'm expressing a
part of myself that you might not like
or you
you know i can't control your reaction
to this and
i had been in relationships in the past
where i had revealed an insecurity
like
i was jealous of somebody you know i
felt threatened by somebody else
and
it was fed back to me that that was
unattractive
and in my mind
that
that kind of stuck
i think there is a especially in a lot
of men there is a kind of
there's a kind of double thing going on
in their head where they go yeah yeah i
know that's really important but i'm not
saying that
because if i say that she's not going to
think i'm cool anymore
i've spent a lot of time curating this
sexy alpha core image
that has attracted this person you
really think i'm going to jeopardize
that by showing an actual weakness
something that and i'm again i'm not
talking about the weakness of i cry in
movies that's not vulnerability that you
know that's going to be cute
you know that she's gonna see that and
go oh my god he's sensitive too
that's not vulnerability
real vulnerability is
this is something that
i never really wanted anyone to see
and
and i'm taking a risk
that when you see this
you're gonna still think that i'm what
you want
have you got something in mind when you
say that when you had a conversation
with audrey and you think now this is
one of the things where i wouldn't
normally have had the
safety i think that for me
times when i was anxious i would
normally bottle those up
and keep them to myself
i wouldn't express what i was anxious
about or what was doing that to me
times if we were arguing
where i wouldn't
really be honest about
why i was upset um
i'd give the kind of
strong version of why i was upset
the pr version yeah yeah but i wouldn't
give the real reason i was upset that
went to the core of me not feeling
enough
of me not feeling good enough of me
feeling scared of me
feeling like something was being
triggered that i didn't know how to
handle
sometimes even when i was in pain and
there would be other situations from my
past where i would kind of not want to
reveal how much pain i was in with my
head
because i was worried that someone might
determine this is not i can't
i don't want to deal with this so i kind
of keep it to myself
for a lot of guys their experience of
growing up wasn't one where being
vulnerable would have been rewarded
and then you add on to that the
additional layer of
as a guy we've been culturally led to
believe that being the
caricatured alpha male
that's what women want
and some of our experiences have
confirmed that
we lost out to the guy in high school
who was much meaner than us
and who we knew was not a very nice
person
but he had his pick
and that that's quite scarring for a guy
because you go what does that mean yeah
what do what do i so i have to be more
like that
and so we close parts of ourselves down
and and then it's and then you know
god forbid you come across or have a
relationship with someone who confirms
that yeah
now you really feel like i need to be
that guy
and and it can take a lot of
rewiring
and deconditioning to get to a place
where you go
oh the if i keep if i keep being this
way i'm actually going to attract i'm
just going to continue to attract people
who do value the wrong things who are
looking for an instagram
man
can you do that from the jump though i
was just thinking about some of my
friends in my head and i was thinking
they're going to hear that and i know
some of my friends who are actually
probably scared
of especially at the start in the dating
phase of
laying it out so they come they put the
makeup on they get the hair done they go
get the tan whatever and their objective
is i just need to keep this [ __ ]
person and i believe the way to keep
them is just you know keep trying to be
that sexy perfect at what point do you
go from sexy perfect to
listen i'm you know pretty [ __ ] up in
a number of ways
i think that we have to
there's a way to
firstly vulnerability in the beginning
of dating
isn't
it
well
vulnerability is is can be really
attractive
but not
in a way where you've exposed all of
your wounds
and the things you don't like about
yourself instantly and offloaded i guess
exactly there's a
you know it's fine to talk about
something that you're
working on or
you know even in a playful tone kind of
nod to something that you're not very
good at
but that's not the same i remember being
on a tv show
in australia
where
i
there was this one woman she was an
amazing woman but every time she went on
a date
it would just be a kind of
all on the surface laughing and just on
the surface on the surface on the
surface on the surface and i was like
part of the problem is these guys that
go on dates with you by the end of the
day
they don't feel connected to you in any
way and the reason they don't feel
connected to you is because there's no
real
vulnerability at that stage
so i said the next day i want you to
actually connect and be a little
vulnerable
now what she did with that advice is
when on the next first date
and told
the story of her dad getting in a car
accident
that changed her whole life in a really
awful way at the time
and
i was i had to say at the time
when i said vulnerability i didn't mean
go and tell the story of the worst thing
that's happened to you in your life
vulnerability
can be
paying someone a compliment
because in a way when you pay someone a
compliment you're handing them a little
power right not in a bad way but you're
saying like there's something great
about you and i'm acknowledging it and
now you know that i think that you're
great in some way
or it can be laughing at somebody else's
is joke or it can be
talking about something that you really
enjoy doing that's a little bit nerdy
that you you know
i might not put on social media all the
time but it is something i actually do
in my spare time that's kind of geeky
but i love it
sometimes or even if it's not geeky if
it's just something you're super
passionate about and you talk about
something with passion that's a
vulnerable act to to express that you're
passionate about something
is vulnerable because they may not think
that thing is cool or or even just to be
passionate is to be vulnerable
you might think that my passion is too
much or you might think it's silly or
so you could be vulnerable about the
right things early on and the more
someone gets to know you
the more you can kind of
let them in on some of the things that
you struggle with vulnerability isn't
necessarily revealing all of our
insecurities all at once
and one important reason for that
is because when we tell an insecurity
i tell you something i don't like about
my face
i'm telling you what to think about my
face
i'm not letting you have your own
opinion of my face
you can take the view that there's some
part of your body or there's something
you're
not a fan of in yourself you can take
that opinion
but you don't get to be the opinion for
everybody else
the reason we're saying it is because
we're almost trying to beat them to it
you know let me just tell you that i
don't like this thing about myself
because then i'll feel better that's out
in the open but i'm presupposing what
you're going to think
about it that's an awful quality people
have that self-disparaging thing it's
really insidious in many ways and that
isn't vulnerability
that's a different thing from
vulnerability vulnerability can be
acknowledging that there's something
that
you don't like about yourself all the
time that can be an act of vulnerability
but you have to suspect yourself if your
instinct with someone you don't know
that well is to immediately go to that
place
i've been in relationships where i felt
like my partner was trying to fix me
and it really is a shitty feeling
for men i think it really emasculates us
as well right we want to be
i guess perfect we want to just make our
woman happy i've been in relationships
where i felt like she was trying to fix
me
and it [ __ ] sucked
that's a rough situation to be in it's
really i had a conversation with her
about it where i was like
by the way when you when you do that
thing where you try and correct correct
me constantly what you're actually also
doing as a consequence is saying that
i'm not good enough
i remember having that conversation with
her fortunately she was someone that
could really listen but women i think
women and men
i only can speak from the perspective of
women because i've only ever been on the
receiving end of it from women but um
what do women need to know about that of
this because a lot of them do it they
they meet someone he might be they're
doing this he might be down the pub too
much he might be have this bad habit
this thing
what do they need to know about this
desire they have sometimes to try and
fix us
does it work where does it lead well i
think
people have to suspect themselves in the
beginning if they're choosing people
that they're not aligned with in the
first place
that i think is a the fixing thing is
often a big symptom of the fact that
instead of choosing a partner you chose
a project of some kind
right
and now i'm unhappy because i needed
these things from the beginning but this
person isn't doing them but i knew that
in the beginning it's not like i
suddenly found out that he enjoys going
to the pub
our first four dates were in a pub
you know
the guy likes a drink i i knew that in
the beginning and does that mean there's
a certain level of acceptance that's
required when you meet someone
well i think that we have to
we have to
um
to a certain
extent say am am i at peace with
who this person is today
because if i'm not
why would i get into a relationship with
them
i'm literally getting into a
relationship on a wager
that they're going to become what i want
what are the chances of that
it goes back to the point we were saying
about this inauthentic initial
connection when you you kind of you're
not really sure who you are
and you might also have a presumption
that the bits you don't like about them
you're not going to mention it just yet
or you know you're going to kind of
maybe not 12 months in you're going to
start mentioning that that's really a
big problem to you but you connected and
authentically from the start so
yeah i just i just i'm totally thinking
about my own experience of that and the
other part of it was hugely my fault in
the sense that i would compromise
so say that i loved watching the
football and she didn't want me to watch
the football or whatever
sure if i can turn the football off for
the first couple of months just to keep
happy families and then this resentment
starts building where you go i [ __ ]
miss the football and you're the reason
i can't watch it you know what i mean
again that's like i was inauthentic i
wasn't honest and we all in some way are
prone to that we we are trying to
we're trying to oil the joints of of
early dating so that everything moves in
this nice smooth romantic
direction and
and we kind of
if we're not careful we do end up
playing a part that we think will just
create the most
energy
the most good energy the most romantic
energy
i i think that what i've learned
as a personal lesson is
that i would
judge things very quickly in people
without trying to understand
what was behind them
like why
why is this thing important to you
why do you like doing this what is it
about this thing what because it's very
easy when someone's different
to how we are
it's very easy to decide what that means
yeah amen to decide what the intention
must be behind that yeah and then to
judge someone on that
and
one of the things i think would help
people because it's very easy to say
well date people who you already
like the way they are and don't date
people or don't go any further with
people that do things you don't like
that's a
oversimplification that
what i would say to people is there's
always going to be differences between
you and the person you date there's
always going to be things that
you i'm not talking about things that
you genuinely ethically
abhor
that's a problem right but if someone is
doing things that are different
than what you do or what you enjoy
take a moment to be curious about that
thing
what is it for them
about that thing that they really like
what does it represent to them
what's driving them there why are they
that way
i have found that to be an immensely
connecting experience because you may do
something different to me but why you
like that thing
might actually
resonate with me
in terms of why i like this thing
i might find that we're actually at the
core
quite similar even though the way
those values or those desires or those
needs
are represented on the surface is
different
and i think people give up a lot of
great people because of their immediate
judgment of the differences
because they haven't actually sought to
understand the the connections that are
under the surface
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast my girlfriend
came upstairs yesterday when i was
having a shower and she said to me that
she tried the heel protein shake which
lives on my fridge over there and she
said it's amazing low calories you get
your 20 odd grams of protein you get
your 26 vitamins and minerals and it's
nutritionally complete in the protein
space there's lots of things but it's
hard to find something that is nice
especially when consumed just with water
and that is nutritionally complete and
that has
about 100 calories in total while also
giving you your 20 grams of protein
if you haven't
tried the cured protein product do give
it a try the salted caramel one if you
put some ice cubes in it and you put it
in a blender and you try it is as good
as pretty much any milkshake on the
market just mixed with water it's been a
game changer for me because i'm trying
to drop my calorie intake and i'm trying
to be a little bit more healthy with my
diet so this is where heel fits in my
life thank you hill for making a product
that i actually like the salted caramel
is my favorite i've got the banana one
here which is the one my girlfriend
likes but for me salted caramel is
the one
what's your longest relationship
ever
proper one
two years two and a half years
mine's roughly the same yeah
you don't know what it's like to go 50
years in a relationship right are you
not scared
on any level
do you not have a fear
of boredom
i have humility about
long-term relationships you've just got
a fiance as well that's a as you wrote
on that caption a forever commitment
right
i have massive humility about
commitments like that in the sense that
like i said to you earlier in this
conversation i don't pretend to know
about things i don't know
but do you personally have a fear of
boredom in your relationship because i i
don't she's going to listen to this i i
wonder i think well i've never i've only
ever done two or three years so what how
do you get 30 years in and still have
the spice and
you know i love her you know
well i think that firstly it's
you you have to look at
i almost take it out of the context of
relationships and say
there's lots of areas of life where
you could say
how do you
not
drink or not get high
and not eventually find life boring
where you need to do that
but then you also know if you're
drinking or getting high there's a cost
to that right it's a there's an actual
cost it it
makes you feel like crap afterwards
there's a hangover
and and so there's a price to pay for
that
i don't think of it just in terms of
will i get bored i i i'm always thinking
in terms of okay but what's
the other option
and has the other option ever worked for
me
now the answer to has the other option
ever worked for me is no
i got to a point in my life where i felt
like i have empirically proven
that
this thing doesn't work
casual relationships
don't make me
they they don't make me happy
there's a you know
it literally is just a feeling followed
by hangover
and that was became reliable in my life
where i just went oh this doesn't work
for me to continue down that path would
be
literally that definition of insanity
i'm well i'm gonna be i suddenly am
gonna
find the right set of casual flings
that's gonna make me happy
it just it's nonsense
i got to a point in my life where
i
i saw two things happened
i met someone
who
had everything that i could ever want in
someone that you would build with
not to mention the obvious stuff the
chemistry the you know the fun we have
together and all of those things we're
all there
i'm not one of those people who you know
when people talk about like a
relationship as if
chemistry's overrated you just need
someone who's a great teammate or
whatever i i don't think chemistry is
overrated i think an absence of
chemistry
can
be dire
and will hurt you
but those things were there
but what was also there is i thought
this is someone
that i can really build with
and i'm in a place in my life where i
want to build
because there's so much more that can
come from
building something here there's so much
more that can come from
the beauty of what gets built than just
like for me dating was like resetting
every time
it was like go build a
lay a couple of bricks down and then
move on again and reset reset reset it's
like renting
it yeah it was like there's nothing yeah
every time you leave i'm
i'm back to to the same place now
there's nothing wrong i have no judgment
on any of that if someone's enjoying
being single if someone wants to do that
if it makes them happy
i have no judgment anywhere i'm not
i don't want to be an evangelist for a
long-term relationship
i can only speak to what feels good to
me in my life and what feels like
i want to be careful not just what feels
good
but
what i actually believe is a
is a path to a more meaningful
life
to a happier life and i truly believe
that is the path that myself and audrey
are on is
she could be single and she could like
she's a beautiful person everyone loves
being around her everyone loves her
company
she could be out there having a ton of
fun she could be out there having all of
this excitement she could
but
she also is someone who values she is
very very big on
valuing the things that lead to
long-term happiness
not
short-term pleasure
and
i always want to be in a relationship
that is you know has pleasure in it
i don't you know i don't want to ever
settle for a relationship where you say
well i'll sacrifice that because
i have all of this other
stuff but
you know i i do believe that it's it
takes i think that takes effort i don't
i'm suspicious of anyone who says when
it's right it's easy
i'm suspicious of that because to me
anything anything long-term any
commitment long-term
requires true effort my last question
then so on that in that example of you
and audrey
i'm trying to get so i'll tell you the
the basis behind my question i'm trying
to understand if we have to be in the
right place and this goes back to my
point about
sort of personal responsibility if we
have to be right when we meet this
person or it's just a case because
there'll be a lot of people listening to
this going okay i've just not met the
right one i've not met my audrey so i'm
going to keep waiting but what i see a
lot is um i met my girlfriend actually
three years ago we dated for a year then
broke up i was totally not the right
person well for all the reasons i said
immature not willing to communicate if
she said something and it was an issue i
thought this isn't perfect so it's not
worth it um i had all of those faults in
me we took a year out i did a lot of
work came back and i genuinely will
marry this person we genuinely have gone
through those things so i think
timing is an issue but largely because
sometimes like we're we're we haven't
done the work we've gone through life
bla i've just i'm too picky i've not
found the right one all of this [ __ ]
what would you say
what would you say to that about the
self work we need to do so that when you
do meet your audrey we're also ready to
receive them well i
i think we have to dispense with this
idea that the one exists
i think that's really really important i
don't think the one exists any more than
the one true career exists
uh i think that we
someone becomes the one by what we build
with them now they have to start with
the right raw materials as do we you
can't just
not anyone can be the person we do that
with but
the person who becomes the one
is the person that
i mean it sounds so funny but
is the person that becomes the one
you know what i mean
if it if you go the distance with
someone they were the one
if you don't go the distance with
someone
then
they weren't the one they weren't
the this idea that there's one person
for you
in the world that you're supposed to
meet
is
silly to me
because it
it gets into all these ideas of love at
first sight and you know i just
we came to each other ready made to be
each other's person i think that's an
insult to the amount of work that a
long-term relationship actually
takes
and
and i think that we get so terrified of
making the wrong decisions in life
that
we avoid the decisions altogether and
that's a form of commitment phobia is
avoiding the decision
because you're so terrified that you're
going to make the wrong choice in a
decision that feels so high stakes
i
i never um
i realized
i never
i always used to kind of when i was
younger
friends of mine that would get tattoos
i'd be like you're insane
you're crazy why would you
put something on your
arm that you can never take off again
that
every fiber of me
said that's a terrible idea
i had never
enjoyed anything for my whole life
i'd never i can't point to a piece of
clothing i've always liked
so why would i think why would i have
faith that i'm gonna tattoo something on
my arm and i'm still gonna like it 20
years from now
that freaked me out
and why i came to realize not with
everyone who gets tattoos there are
plenty of foolish tattoos out there
but what i did realize is that
actually a lot of the people that i knew
who got tattoos just had a different
relationship
with
the idea of permanence i i knew someone
with a lot of tattoos and she said
you know this just the meaning changes
over time she was a client of mine who
said i
over time
they come to mean different things and
they kind of evolve with me
and so in a way
though to you it may look like the same
tattoo to me it's
it's always evolving in its meaning and
and what it represents that's actually
what someone said to me because i was
telling them i was going to ask one of
my team in the room that i was gonna ask
ask you this question and he's been in a
marriage for some time he has kids and
he said well you have different
relationships with them over time and
that adage of you fall in love with them
over and over again in different ways
right
i couldn't agree more
and
i can't speak as somebody who has done
it already
i can only
speak as someone who i realize that my
relationship with the idea of permanence
has
not
been a very productive one has it been
for me it was definitely an insecure one
and it's get a fearful one well i think
that you know there's a oliver burkman
who i you may have met i think you maybe
interviewed oliver burkman
his book for anyone who's struggling
with
with being ready for commitment is a
really powerful book you could read that
book as a dating book
uh because he he talks about the
the issue of deciding
deciding to do something and then
the thing that we decide on we resolve
to make that
as good as we can make it because by
definition you can't experience all of
life
you can't experience every man in the
world you can't experience every woman
in the world you can't like it
you can't
so
when we're trying to what he describes
it as is almost a fear of our own
mortality or a lack of acceptance of our
own mortality he talks about it in a
time management sense that the fact that
we're trying to cram so many things into
our day is really a representation of
our lack of acknowledgement that we're
going to die
right i keep telling myself i'm going to
do all of these things that i'll never
get to but because i can't come to terms
with the fact that i'm going to die and
i'm not going to get to do even a
quarter of these things i'm planning to
do because if you really understand how
short life is you know you're not going
to go to half of the countries you want
to go to so you better start picking the
ones you really want to go to however
that make that seems to make the stakes
of every decision really high right
this is berkman's point that it makes
the stakes of every decision really high
and that would make us even more
decisive even more indecisive my god if
you're already telling me that i have to
carefully select the books i'm going to
read because i'm only going to get to
read one percent of of the books that i
ever even want to read let alone the
number of books out there
then
how would i ever choose what book to
read next when i know i'm only going to
read 60 more
in my whole life or a hundred more in my
whole life
what he says which is so compelling is
that
there's there's no
one right book there's no one right
country there's no one right person
there's the person that and there's the
person we in we decide we resolve to
make the best relationship with
there's the country we decide to make
the most of living in
there's the job that we decide to make
the most of
and
the way i think about it is
not people
settling is a very
um
emotive loaded word
i used to write in people's books when i
signed when people would bring me on
tour a copy of get the guy
i used to write as standard in the front
of their book never settle
and
i now
look at that and i'm like
i don't think that was strong advice
i don't think that was strong advice
because
what i did was demonize
the word settling which self-development
tends to do
it's all about optimization
never settle
and i was coming from that kind of
maximizing optimizing self-development
place
but there's a difference between
settling for
and settling on
settling four
says that you had a standard
that
you accepted less than
settling on
says
i'm gonna
put my focus and my energy on
something
and it's gonna be extraordinary because
i'm gonna make it extraordinary
and it sounds voluntary doesn't it
whereas a form is kind of like you were
given that and four is like i gave up
yeah yeah yeah settling on is i made a
conscious decision i settled on
living in london i didn't settle for
living in london i decided i this is a
great city yes there are many other
great cities but this is a great city
and i am gonna make living in london
incredible for myself i'm settling on
living in london and i for years i
noticed in my language
even though i've been living in la ill
in la for 10 years anytime someone would
ask me so is la home i'd go i don't know
i might leave i'm right next year i
might not be here i'm not sure we'll see
i've been doing my job for 15 years i
clearly in a practical sense do not have
an issue with commitment
i've been doing what i do for a very
long time most people more longer than
most people do any job but if you'd
asked me in general
do you see yourself doing this for your
whole life i'd say i don't know i mean
we'll see
now
that's okay to build in flexibility but
not if it's
a way of ever avoiding settling on
something because when we don't settle
on something we actually rid ourselves
the opportunity of making it the best
it can be
and and
iron when we were going through a time
recently where we were talking about
should we stay in la or should we go
somewhere else you know what do we think
and we kind of thought about all
different places we might go and we did
this whole
exercise this mental exercise of
thinking about all of these places we
could live and would live and so on
we ended up
settling on la
and we came right back to where we
started but but we both said
actually no we want to be here and what
was really funny is the moment we
decided
okay no we're going to be here
we started doing all of these little
things in the house and we went out and
bought a couple more plants
and we started thinking about what we
wanted to put on this wall that doesn't
have anything on it right now and we in
other words the moment we decided to
settle on
we started investing differently and
consciously
in the house that we were actually in
and
that's actually where all the enjoyment
comes from is once you start investing
where you are
you start making the best of where you
are and you lose this idea
that there is some perfect state of
anything
outside of where you are perfectly comes
back to your point about the ingredients
as well and making the most of where you
have settling on your ingredients
matthew thank you honestly i could sit
here for 10 hours
um this was so much fun thank you for
having me and thank you for such
thank you thank you for such thoughtful
questions like you
your vulnerability comes across and
that's not
you know when you've when you've
achieved a lot
it it's easy for your identity to
calcify and and yours hasn't and you
stay vulnerable and
it's reflected in the kind of
conversation you're open to having so i
i really appreciate it well yeah i sit
here every very often and i get to hear
from people like you about the
importance of a vulnerability being
honest with myself and controlling and
containing ego so again this has been a
real refresher about what's important in
life and i i really really you know
you've really reinforced the central id
i mean so many central ideas but the one
that i think about in the context of
i mean the ingredients one is definitely
the one that will stay with me the most
but
as it relates to the relationship part
that important the importance of men and
i plead with men because i know they're
listening
trying vulnerability out in their
relationships it was the thing that
changed my relationship the thing that
changed my life in that regard it's the
thing it's the reason why people listen
to this the reason why this podcast has
done well is because i took the bet on
recording myself at 3am saying i was
really struggling with some [ __ ] and
this and masturbation and my family and
all these things that you're not allowed
to talk about make you feel
uncomfortable vulnerability has been the
thing that happens before all the good
things in my life and you're a real um a
testament to vulnerability and also the
the importance of it we have a closing
tradition on this podcast where the
previous guest writes a question for the
next guest so our previous guest wrote a
question for you that's cool
yes
it is because it's a nice through thread
so they're all connected which we love
um
okay so i i look at the question when i
open the book and i looked at it i
opened the book a second ago
the question is
what is your dark side
i i think my dark side is
the part of me that thinks
everyone
has an agenda
that they can't be trusted
and that
if they're being
even if they're being nice there must be
some angle
somewhere
and therefore i should be on my guard
and suspicious at all
times
that i think is my dark side and i think
that that
i think that has
been one of the things in recent years
that i've really had that's been part of
my vulnerability
is
opening myself up to
acts of kindness and connection that
aren't driven by
any agenda
and making peace with the times where
they are but i was
i i
brought forward my best
and most authentic self anyway do you
know where that came from
[Music]
i don't know
i don't know i i
i don't even know when it started
i i can't remember if i ever felt like
that when i was a kid
but certainly as an adult
that's been something that i've
i think has
it's been a part of my life that
i've really had to let go of and one of
the things that allowed me to
start to let go of it was
real
friendships
real friendships where
i noticed that there were people around
me that just
were really kind
or if i needed
help
if i needed advice
and i think probably during when during
that period of time where i was
desperate with with my chronic pain
there were people that
gave me their time and their energy
even if they didn't know how to help
there were people that had no reason to
give me
time and energy it would have been
perfectly acceptable for them to not
who decided to give me
their time even people who had no time
and that
a kind of that limiting belief
started to dissolve in the face of that
and it made me want to
you know it really made me want to
represent that in the world and not even
if people can take advantage
not going into life waiting for that
waiting to
to like spot that but instead just going
some people will take advantage and
other people won't but
i want to be someone who trusts people
thank you
thanks steve really wonderful
conversation and for all the reasons
i've described you're a really
necessary important voice in the world
and if we need more men that are willing
to be vulnerable and open because i
think it's a catalyst for a very
important systemic change in us as men
um
receiving and achieving what we want and
when i reflect on the statistics around
men their mental health and the
consequences of their ill mental health
a lot of it is rooted in an absence of
expression so i love having these
conversations thank you so much matthew
thank you sir
quick one as you might know crafted are
one of the sponsors of this podcast and
crafted are a jewellery brand and they
make really meaningful pieces of jewelry
i think i've worn this piece for almost
a year
it hasn't broken hasn't changed color
because it's really really good quality
and it costs roughly
50 quid i'm not the type of person that
has rolexes or jewelry that cost tens of
thousands of pounds i want pieces that
are reliable that look beautiful and
that holds meaning and significance for
me and that's exactly why i've worn
crafted for so long and when we had the
conversation about them sponsoring this
podcast i was so unbelievably keen for
them to do so check it out if you're a
guy crafted london.com and yeah if you
get any pieces of crafted tag man let me
know what you think
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
you